areopoli is the name of a town meaning
the city of ares
the ancient god of war in greek
mythology it was here
200 years ago this year that the greek
war of independence from the ottoman
empire began
as greece prepares to celebrate that
bicentennial
it is again extending its sovereignty
this time
out to sea under the united nations law
of the sea coastal states may extend
their territorial waters to 12 nautical
miles from shore
greece is now doing so off its west
coast facing
italy and warns that it will do the same
in the aegean sea
facing turkey
everyone here feels that greece is
standing up to its full height for the
first time in its history
i think it should happen of all of
greece's coastline
this is cape teneron the southernmost
tip
of mainland greece where the ionian and
aegean seas
meet on the far side of this peninsula
in the ionian
is where greece is to extend its
territorial waters to 12 nautical miles
from shore
and on this side of the peninsula in the
aegean greece is to maintain
territorial water of six nautical miles
for now
that's because turkey has threatened war
should greece
apply the law of the sea in the aegean
giving it control of 72 percent of its
waters
turkey is among a minority of nations
that haven't signed the law of the sea
greece and turkey nearly went to war
last summer over a different type of
maritime zone
the continental shelf which extends
beyond territorial waters
next week they will restart talks
stalled for four years
on determining the boundaries of the
continental shelf
greece insists its territorial water
will not be under discussion
and its extension in the ionian now is
meant to underline that
if you enter the negotiations under the
present
arrangement of six nautical miles
without putting on the table the
possible extension
it's as if you accept that any agreement
in any arrangement
in the limitation will start from six
so that is actually giving up your
rights
to 12. if the greeks believe they have
their right up to extend up to 12 they
have to put it on the table now they
have to say so
because that's what you are going to
negotiate relations between greece and
turkey have entered a difficult and
confrontational phase
in which even admitting what is under
discussion is a delicate matter
the fundamental question however is
whether the law
will prevail over any threats of
violence
john cerropolos al-jazeera in the
southern peloponnese